في ملاطيا وفي هذه المناطق الطرق الطرق
وهناك صعوبات في ايصال المعونات
الى هذه المناطق ويتم استخدام الطرق
البديله
ايضا هناك بعض
الاشكاليات مثل سقوط الصخور في هذه
المنطقه التي تسد الطرق
[موسيقى]
فيما يتعلق
الشبكات التواصل
وايضا ايصال
الطاقه الى هذه المنطقه
وقمنا
بايصال الى اجزاء من المدن
الطاقه
والان
مركز المزداد
مدن بعض الاماكن انقطع الكهرباء مقطعه
ولكن ما عدا هذه المناطق
جميع المدن المنكوبه يتم ايصال الكهرباء
اليها ايضا
في
بعض المولدات الكهرباء يتم طبعا استخدامها
بشكل الحذر لكي لا ايضا تؤثر على حرائق
كوارث جديده
وزير
التعليم اعلنا ان المدارس ستنقطع عن
الدراسه لغايه 13 من الشباط وسيكون ايضا
مضافات مفتوحه
المنكوبين كما ايضا صاله الرياضه
وايضا المباني المتعلقه بالتدريس ستكون
مفتوحه للباك في الجامعات ايضا
تم اعلان العطله
الاعلان عن استخدام المباني المتعلقه
بالسكن الطلاب
المباني
الرياضيه وما الى ذلك سيتم استخدامها لواء
المنكوبين والمتادير من الزلزال في كوريا
وانطاليا
في هذه المدن
تم ايضا توفير
مباني حكوميه لتوفير فرص
الاقامه
[موسيقى]
المؤقته للمنكوبين
ايضا بالنسبه
اشخاص
نحن
انقاذ محترفة نطلب منهم اخلاء الاماكن لكي
يسيحوا الفرصه
لفرق الانقاذ المحترفه لتعمل بشكل افضل
سنواصل عمليه اجراء بعض الاماكن المنكوبه
ونحن
نشارك ايضا في هذه العمليه بالتنسيق ايضا
بالنسبه
الخيم والبطانيات والمدفات الكهربائيه
والمساعدات الاخرى سيتم توفيرها
للمنكوبين ايضا
ايصال المساعدات من باقي المدن التركيه
الى المدن المنكوبه ايضا
نريد ان نعلم المواطنين ان المساعدات اذا
تاخرت في هذا لا يعني انها لن تصل في هذا
الطريق ايضا في موضوع
الغذاء
سيكون هناك
المطابخ المتنقله
التي ستقدم وجبات
الطعام الساخنه
للمنكوبين في اشراف او تحت اشراف الهلال
الاحمر التركي
وبالتنسيق منه ايضا
يشارك او ست الوزارات المختلفه في عمليه
توصيل الغذاء
للاشخاص الذين يحتاجونه
طبعا المساعدات التي تاتي من الخارج
ثلاثيه ماء من موضوع او الدول التي
ارسلت المساعدات نحن قمنا بتوجيه هذه
المساعدات الى المناطق
المتاثره من ايضا السدود
من قبل
المياه التركيه واذا ما لحق بها ضرر او او
كان هناك اي خطر تم اعداد تقارير حول هذا
الموضوع
والان حتى الان الامور مستتبه ولا يوجد
هناك اي خطر حول السدود
كل شيء تحت السيطره
ساكتفي بهذا القدر
لكن هناك موضوع اخر
وفي عشر
مدينه مدن طبعا
ممكن ان يتوجهوا اليها بشكل مجاني ممكن ان
يحصلوا على الخبز
وايضا
نقوم بعمليه التنسيق ايضا واعلن ان الخبز
سيكون بالمجان مره اخرى
اتمنى من الله الرحمه
المتوفين والشفاء العاجل للجرحى
ايضا اريد ان اقول بان نحن في وقت الشده
ان تكاتف ونظهر
تكافل حقيقه كشعب تركي وبقياده الرئيس
اردوغان قمنا بمواجهه ومجابهه الكثير من
الكوارث الطبيعيه
وهذه الكوارث الطبيعيه كانت كوارث
عملاقه وكبيره
وايضا ضربت البلاد
مره اخرى اريد ان الفت النظر
انشطه
لا تعتمدوا اي
اي من الارقام التي تصدر عن اي شخص سوى
الارقام التي تصدر عن اداره افاد
وهناك بعض المغرضين الذين يظللون الراي
العام وانتبهوا الى ذلك شكرا جزيلا اذا
كان اي سؤال ممكن ان نجيب عليه
[موسيقى]
الصوت لغير واضح
قليل
تحدثت عن عمليه الاجلاء
في
المنطقه التي تحدثنا عنها ايضا
هناك
فتح
للمضافات والفنادق في منطقه انطاليا
وميرسين
وسيتم نقل المنكوبين ايضا الى الجامعات
والمدارس والمضافات والسكان او السكن
الطلاب
ستكون مفتوحه لخدمه
المواطنين
ونحن ايضا سنشرف على عمليه الاجلاء
فيما يتعلق بالمحروقات والبنزين
ايضا نعمل على عمليه نقل المحروقات الى
هذه المناطق هناك بعض الطرقات التي تضررت
بفعل الزلزال